devait trouver là amir isabelle boulay
christophe willem pour le ferons sans
bus alors qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
ensemble
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont dans ce sens
philippe à ce que tu as une idée un clip
non non pas sa révision un truc dans le
genre uni la russie à un moment il a vu
il est fort ce jeu là c'est pas tout à
fait
maxime ils vont devenir jurée de la
nouvelle émission de france 2
destinations eurovision qui sera diffusé
mi janvier sur la chaîne
oh bah ouais c'est pas un articulet la
qualité des gouttes j'adore savoir entre
marche i miss you des quelque chose
d'autre il est en train d'allaiter
valéry giscard d'estaing pas y'a un truc
et ça va très bien comme ça vous êtes
merci j'ai très chaud merci ça vous
changera les chéris donc admirer
isabelle boulay christophe willem vont
faire le jury de destination révision le
télé crochet qui va choisir la le groupe
où la personnalité qui va nous
représenter pour l'eurovision c'est ça
alors hier à demi finale une finale en
direct
dix-huit chansons représentés ils ont
alors reçu 1500 ses premiers parité
ville le producteur de the voice 9 alors
à dire la vérité ça ça avait été fait il
ya quelques années ça n'avait pas du
tout marché déjà il fait même une grande
saga pour savoir qui allait nous
représenter à l'eurovision ça avait été
une grande banane en audience mais moi
je
j'adore plus j'adore les trois artistes
mais là je pense que c'est un énorme
erreur eu de france télé oui et outre
les trois français y avait pas juges
européens mais ils ont un petit peu peur
est que le juge européen mais
inconsciemment faire inconsciemment ou
pas d'ailleurs favorise son propre pays
au détriment des candidats français est
vrai que dans la passion
oui j'ai très envie de voir envie de
voir ça en fait la personne catastrophe
c'est ce qu'on appelle une usine a mis
la france des gens qui vont choisir
pendant des mois ça va perdre toute
magie tout suspense effectivement le
juré pas mal
bernard une anecdote de ski berne a
sincèrement surtout ça ne sert à rien on
ne gagnera jamais leur vision et on ne
s'immisce à dominique pourquoi on
gagnera car on ne veut pas gagner car ça
coûte cher dont tous les ans on en voit
une banane et sa examine amir salem ses
meilleures amies rct pas à venir c'est
formidable ça me met à rire il n'a pas
gagné non plus non voilà on dire parce
que je vous dis la vérité le pays qui
gagnent il doit organiser l'année
d'après il faut savoir par exemple un
show en russie comme il l'avait fait je
peux je crois en 2012 ça avait coûté 32
millions d'euros
voilà c'est à dire que 32 millions
d'euros pour france télé il arrête tout
il enlève même les boules de motus le
pipeau d'élise lucet terminé fini oui on
n'est pas là où on veut pas gagner enfin
on n'a pas non plus à l'abri que les
autres payez votre prono si on veut pas
gagner on n'a qu'à pas participer ou ne
plus y participer mais c'est fini c'est
marrant alors si vous avez compris
l'intérieur s'affiche en bas de votre
iphone
c'est la france organisait ce serait une
énorme vitrine 180 2 millions de
téléspectateurs à chaque occasion et
l'europe sa série en avant la france
vitrine de quoi c'est vrai laurent ça
devient un beau coup en gagnent
l'eurovision a besoin d'une force mais
je dépense tous les jours je n'étais sûr
je me raccroche à sac à main un rêve en
fait alors un moteur dans la vie par
mois